un choc au programme de cette 14ème
journée de fédérale 3 versailles
recevait bobigny au stade de
porchefontaine deux équipes au coude à
coude dans la course au top 4 en fin de
saison
malmenés en début de match les versets
et concède rapidement des points ils
sont menés 13 à 0 au bout de 22 minutes
de jeu les bleus arrivent à revenir dans
la partie avec un drop inscrit le score
à la pause trait à trois premières pas
de compliqué parce qu'on savait parce
qu' il n'était pas fatigué c'était début
du match on savait que ça allait très
dense et qu'ils allaient nous mettre de
l'impact physique on a un peu subi en
première mi temps voit le niveau du défi
physique qu'ils étaient plus lourds que
nous donc on a vraiment eu du mal à les
faire tomber
en seconde période verseille pousser la
faute les jours de bobigny et marque un
essai et versailles et reviennent à
hauteur après cette pénalité marque
cette nouvelle pénalité dans les
dernières minutes du match
score final 16 à 13 pour versailles une
bonne n'y a plus rien qui nous arrive
y a plus rien qui nous arrête très très
fiers de vous les gars ont du coeur ils
ont trouvé les solutions et avec du
mouvement et d'intensité on a réussi à
passer devant sur la fin de match
versailles est désormais troisième avec
41 points et peut rêver plus grand s'est
passé quelque chose franchement on
savait que c'était un tournant et
on est contents si on maîtrise bien la
suite de la saison je pense c'est
quelque chose à jouer une qualification
est envisageable
on n'osait pas trop en parler mais avec
ce second bloc il faut s'accrocher 1
s'est pas fait mais on y pense pour
continuer à poursuivre leur bonne série
les versailles i se déplaceront sur le
terrain de vincennes le 16 février
prochain